for decades C++ has been the industry
standard for high-performance computer
programming in fields ranging from
robotics and embedded systems for
artificial intelligence and even video
games see for us a programming language
that is used for sort of the
foundational part or just about anything
we do it sticks in between the
higher-level software and the hardware
and that's a much bigger part of the
world than most people think and so it's
basically everywhere our world is
becoming increasingly autonomous and AI
can be found in more and more
applications C++ is the common thread
between self-driving cars drones and
robotics at Udacity we're working with
C++ experts to prepare students for the
many careers that utilize this
programming language it has a core
domain sort of in between the hardware
and the higher levels of software and
that domain seems to be increasing as we
have many more gadgets it can handle the
complexity of your camera it can handle
your fuel injectors in the steering
wheel on your car as few languages that
can actually do that well Udacity uses a
project driven educational approach in
which students build a portfolio of C++
projects to prove that they are ready
for jobs as C++ engineers as we get more
computerized gadgets we get more C++ C++
will become more useful easier to use
the more powerful into the growth will
carry on it's fun
join our nano degree program and learn
C++ today